I think it's a truism in science that if
you can see something you can study it
what's really exciting about GFP is it's
allowed us to see so much within the
cells that we were not aware of before
when I heard about GFP in that seminar
in 1989 I was very excited about it I
think I was the only person in the
audience that was working on a
transparent animal the nematode center
of datas elegans and at the same time
interested in knowing where genes were
expressed and I realized that if we
could get the DNA for GFP we could
insert that into the genes we were
interested in and now those genes would
cause the production of GFP and we can
see that in the living transparent
animal just by shining blue light onto
the animal and seeing which cells turn
green so the first experiment was to
actually try to see could GFP be made in
something other than the jellyfish at
the time most of the people working on
GFP they all thought this was going to
be impossible but the person who
actually did the first experiment in the
lab was Ghia my name is Gaius kirkin I
was a rotation student in Marty Chafee's
lab when Marty come me up and presented
this fluorescence project I was actually
really excited because for my master's
thesis worked on fluorescence and he
thought that the project with GFP might
be a good match and in general who
doesn't like fluorescence it's really
beautiful and it's just fun to work with
so from the very start what I wanted and
what Douglass wanted was to be able to
show that GFP could actually form a
fluorescent protein one that we could
shine blue light on and see green in
other organisms
mostly I wasn't really expecting the
experiment to work one of the big
reasons being because none of the other
graduate students in the lab really
wanted to touch it they kind of had
looks on their faces like yeah good luck
with that and so that first day in
October about a month after she started
graduate school he was able to look down
the microscope and actually see bacteria
that were glowing green when they were
stimulated by blue light
you